you must be frightened you said you've
only left your house a couple of times
in the last few days and purely by the
fact that you're a female mp
you will be a target under the old
taliban regime you'd have been a target
under this new taliban regime you
believe you are they say that you are
not
why did you stay we've been watching
images of families heading to kabul
airport women and children who are going
to that airport for the sheer fact that
of their sex the fact that they are
women they probably haven't held
positions of power they may not have
held jobs but they are frightened
because they are women why did you
choose to stay in kabul if you believe
you're such a target
you know
it's a question that always
uh
just
uh make me
emotional
not so easy to answer you know
we as a woman leader
as a young generation leader
as as as a person who people trusted
all
we we we have we have some obligations
or some responsibility toward our people
especially the woman
the young woman who believed and trust
that we are a role model or somehow a
responsible one or we can name it anyway
so
when our president just left the country
you know
what happened it broke it broke our
heart as much as the taliban entrance
did not did that our leaders that
i don't call anyone leader in my society
yet i don't believe that we have some
but the people are calling some of our
our warlords or some of our other elders
their leaders
all of them just left it this this
nation beyond everything and anything
could happen to that
to them to the whole nation but they
didn't care and i saw that how it feel
for me so what will be for the all the
nation for the all 15 to 16 million
women and girls how they will feel that
everyone who is capable of living they
are living
and what we will do here the people
need to have a future in their society i
can't believe that
this place afghanistan but what about my
family my nephew my nurses my sisters my
brothers my my friends my relatives and
all other women who who who are not like
in good position in good days but we
were in the bad days they need us too so
we have to be here
but as long as we are capable of doing
something for them if if i can speak
with you
that i'm afraid of and i i should be so
if i can't risk that if i can't speak to
anyone else if i can go out if i can't
share a message to all the women so what
my being in afghanistan in kabul or
being in london or being in in
frankfurt would would what would be the
difference between that
my staying here as a woman i
first of all for the first time after
taliban took over i went to a political
debate in here in kabul in a in
participated in a
local tv program and
it's
talked about women right in the future
of the afghanistan and the government
that is going to be formed so we some of
us would should do that because the
taliban should face us and they should
know that the reality of the society is
this and we have to manage that we have
to lead that this way if we all hide in
ourselves if we all live the country
so how
the woman who is who are not in a in the
position who who not yet independent to
take decision to make decisions and
those women who who who can't like uh
rest they are not as much uh
as we are like
it should be uh something so hard and
difficult for them to come out and talk
about everything we have so many brave
women here and staying here and talking
here and i i've seen many of them like
not as 1000 or 100 but 10 to 20
like a little
limit
amount
and figure were on the street so this is
all
what we need because
before the taliban start ruling the
country they should face us they should
know i just been to to a meeting where
we we spoke about spoken about these
things
so that's why i just stayed for my
family my friends my our uh women of our
son for all of those and for me myself
too that i should feel a little bit
satisfied that i did i tried my my my
basement tried your best and you stayed
with honestly brave brave doesn't even
cover what you've decided to do because
essentially what you're saying is you're
willing to risk your life for democracy
and for the rights of women and girls
what would you say to governments in the
west about the support you need and
female mps from the uk have written a
letter of support what action do you
want from them to help you
thank you so much
actually about our government forming in
these things and about supporting like
a security wise or these things i'm just
disappointed on those fights but coming
to just about the woman of afghanistan
here we have two things first of all
safety and security of those women who
are at high risk fazanica chai one
incredible woman a female mp
in afghanistan